i'm sorry excuse me what yes
little change you mean a transformation
a transformation
claudia conway returned to the american
idol stage on sunday
rocking a new look and some serious
determination
it's beautiful to see the growth in real
time when claudia walked out to sing for
judges katy perry lionel richie and
luke bryan the daisy singer looked
totally shocked by the contestant's
new more mature look i'm sorry excuse me
what yes little change
you mean a transformation transformation
in a pre-taped package
claudia explained that after her first
audition
she faced a lot of opinions on social
media
but it was katie's advice at her first
audition in ojai california
that helped her focus and stay motivated
she believed in me and i could not be
more grateful for that
now i'm just drowning it all out and
telling myself that i can do it
of course the 16-year-old american idol
hopeful is the daughter of kellyanne
conway
who served as senior counsel for former
president donald trump
the teen has been very publicly critical
of her mom over the past few years
and has gained a large following on
tick-tock where she
often feuds with her mom over their
political views
you need extra help what'd you call them
what do you want to know
during her first audition katie told
claudia to silence
all the noise there's a lot of noise
in your life you have to
calm the storm that is around you
meaning
before you sing you need to get off your
phone
you need to stop reading your comments
push it aside
because if not you may not ever
rise above your dad
or your mom it's your choice
okay now flash forward to sunday
claudia got a lot of love after
performing a cover of bishop
briggs river
claudia's journey on idol continues as
she moves into the next round of the
competition the duets
do you guys ever think if you could have
gone through it like if you were on
american idol
would you get through it yeah i don't
know i mean because
because i didn't get my confidence i
mean i'm still getting my confidence
to be completely honest e.t recently sat
down with the judges and
they opened up about just how hard the
competition
really is it's mental gymnastics and
it's really like
it's the master class obstacle course in
a
crunch period amount of time i think you
know lionel said something the other day
you know
you can't let other talent
psych you out that's right you have to
be what you
are and what you are just because this
person
may be technically the best singer in
all of america i don't
they may not have the personality that
you have
they don't have the x factor so control
what you can
control handle your business